So now we've gone through the basics of javascript syntax: structuring and
interacting with JSON data, and requesting data from a server. Now, we need to
talk about how to interface to the browser. More specifically, we need to talk
about the DOM, or document object model. The DOM is an interface to the
structure of an HTML.document,
for example, the head or body element. The DOM allows us to access and modify
our HTML document dynamically, using Javascript. Our game is primarily going to
exist within a single element, the canvas, which we'll get into later. But what
this means is that we won't have a lot of reason to heavily access the DOM.
In fact we're only going to need a few things. So let's take a look at a quick
example. Let's say you want to validate whether a user has entered a valid
password into an input field. Here's how you would do that using the DOM API in
Javascript. You can see the basic HTML here with the form and the password
input and the submit button, and we have a script down here where we start
executing our javascript. First, we have this document.getElementById method.
What this does is grab a DOM element of the given id. In this case, it's
exampleForm, which is right here, so we would grab this entire form. When
it's submitted, we run this function in here. Now, you don't really need to
worry about the passwordRegex too much. We're interested in this part down
here. Now if the password doesn't match, then we create a new "p" tag element,
assuming it doesn't already exist. We check if it exists by again using the
document.getElementById method and checking for the ID "notify". If it doesn't
exist we use the document.createElement method specified at "p" tag. This
parameter is just the name of a type of element. For example p or form or
canvas. Now we set the text content of that p tag to this bit here and we set
the ID attribute to notify. That way, if we submit multiple times, we don't
simply create a new p tag every single time. Finally, we grab a reference to the
body tag, since the body element has an ID of body we can do that, and we
append "notify" to the body. Now if we look at this in our browser, we can see
we have an input form with a submit button and you can see our basic HTML down
here. However, if we submit an incorrect password -- press submit -- we can see that
this pops up right here, which is the text that we set our p tag to. You can
also see that this p tag was created down here. With an idea of notify and the
correct text. You'll also see that if we keep pressing Submit again, more p tags
don't get created, since we made that check.